2015 has been a wonderful year for video
games many of whom have been who which
which probably about people many of
which have been open-world video games
that we already have The Witcher 3 Wild
Hunt earlier this year of course Mad Max
came it this week as it Malik your Solid
V the phantom pain he has come to he
hasn't got a computer Brendan Justin hey
Wald here to have a little chinwag I bet
I guess what what makes a good
open-world game um one of the things I'm
interested about is that our game of the
year last year
Middle Earth shadow of Mordor a
fantastic game really enjoyed it last
year but I can already think of a
handful of open-world games this year
that have trumped it already like open
world games third-person ones especially
really come on a long way like Far Cry 4
GTA 5 like we're in the sort of golden
age for them at the moment Animal
Crossing of course right there yes Kurtz
so I guess I wanna ask you guys and what
it is bed o what makes a good open-world
game and where do other games for
thought Justin first of all I think one
of the ways that some open-world games
really fail isn't trying to give you so
though I mean you get either extreme you
either get there trying to do too much
like here's a world where there's just
[ __ ] everywhere Assassin's Creed 3 yeah
a perfect example of a beautiful world
filled with things to do you didn't ever
want to do it's like this is actually
getting the way of my enjoyment versus
something that's what was that rockstar
game that had the great feast on theft
auto v la noir la noir a go it was just
a sparse world that was like this is
really cool to explore I want to do more
but there's nothing like yeah I guess
I'll just fast travel just need to turn
around but that's a waste of my time
so like a delicate balancing act of
content against being overwhelmed
because that was certainly how I felt
about an assassin's Creed
I think Black Flag is one of those games
where some people are actually sort of
more predisposed to having long laundry
list of things to do and then some
people like myself and Justin are kind
of like intimidated by it I like things
to do Assassin's Creed 2 is a perfect
example of a game yes I collected
everything it's one of the last games
that I 100% with complete aplomb I was
so excited to 100% it and then that's
why I like getting to his heads great I
was so disappointed that it didn't have
that
same feel I didn't capture me in that
same way but hey yo Peter you're someone
who definitely plays a lot a lot of
these open-world games but do you have
time to collect everything is that do I
play a lot of them lately I've been
playing a lot of it yeah it's very it's
it's difficult because you know we we
sort of work on a tight schedule here
where we have to get games done and hit
deadlines and such and I try to give as
much time as I can but it's very
important that the things that you're
doing are interesting and when they are
interesting I come back to them because
I want to I certainly don't complete
games because I feel like it's well when
it's my job to do it I do it but you
know like I don't feel like if after I'd
beaten a game and done the review like
well I better go back and finish stuff
because it's there waiting for me it's
known the trophy mine yeah yeah it's
like trophies it's like I want to get
back into phantom pain because the
things that I'm doing they may be
similar to something I did a while back
right they're 150 side missions in that
game that's a lot but they think is with
every one of those you get like a little
snippet of audio that's like we're gonna
get the funding for this mmm the Soviets
huh no they couldn't like me like it
there's always a story B that ties it
back into it I think a lot of open-world
games fail to give you anything beyond a
task with a minor reward that doesn't
tie into the bigger picture of the world
and that's what's really important to me
because the difference between an
open-world game in a game where you're
just given distinct levels that are kind
of disconnected is the fact that you
have free roam within a world you have
the right to observe what you wish and
make you know obtuse or tuss I'd what
this world is all about rather than
being spoon-fed to you so blatantly and
when a game just gives you chores you're
not learning anything from them what
you're three did that so beautifully
like that was a world where like I was
thrown in and I loved getting more story
and finding out new things about stuff
but I was also happy to just like I'm
gonna go see what's over there I'm gonna
get in a boat and like that was one of
the first things I didn't what's the
world open up I just gotten a boatneck
traveled to the to this next huge city
and it's like there's so much to to
explore that was intriguing it's it's
almost like the open world genre has
like come from like two different genres
you had your you're sort of role-playing
games that were large like things like
you know I'm thinking back on like old
Elder Scrolls games like dragonfall or
things like that which like eventually
turned into the Oblivion's of the world
and the the fallouts and the skyrim
isn't one and then you kind of just had
like traditional third-person action
games which had worlds that just got
bigger so instead of having
games like you know maybe MDK which were
like large open world game or large open
areas that you like fought within then
instead of them being like sort of
larger linear levels one after the other
they sort of just broke them out so that
you've got your infamous and your
crackdown and stuff like that and kind
of like Mad Max like that seems like a
game where it's it's you've just got a
bunch of missions but instead of them
being like one by one they're just like
one after you they're there in an open
world or Far Cry for instance but then
games like ground zeroes or like The
Witcher 3 that they almost seem like
they are real worlds that they've
created and yeah and they feel more
fleshed out and to your point if there's
like instead of just having a laundry
list of missions to do you're you have
more I guess agency to sort of explore
and figure out what you want to do
yourself I mean you feel like the world
isn't centered around you mmm you know
you feel like you are a part of it and I
think that that's very very important in
games like you know Mad Max tries to do
that like it has different factions in
it that are their own little societies
but you're always the center of
attention and obviously that's the job
of a main character but you have to be
the center of attention but you want to
feel like even if I wasn't in this world
it's still happening around me right
exactly yeah so you go into a mission in
the phantom pain right and it's not like
like you're going there because there's
some important person that's showing up
whether you're there or not that would
happen and like it's it's it's up to you
to take care of that guy because you
know what's going to happen and it's the
right time to do it you know but like
Mad Max just show up it's like Oh max is
here you know like that kind of thing
it's I don't know like even Assassin's
Creed is which is probably sort of
threads the line between the two in a
way like that always felt like a world
that was just going on like Grand Theft
Auto like going back as far as gta3
always kind of felt like a world that
was happening even one and two actually
they felt like like sandbox is that were
like actually or not sound back so they
felt like real worlds that were actually
happening and in The Witcher 3 is
probably the best example where like
even when you get involved [ __ ] doesn't
go the way you wanted so you don't even
feel that powerful yourself because when
you when you try to do good like it's
sort of you know reality kicks in and it
gets skewed some other way yeah it's
probably a weird example but the Legend
of Zelda Majora's Mask is a game that I
think imitates that open-world feel and
having a world that were stuffs
happening all around you because it was
a game where you do have things you can
explore and you know things are gonna
happen whether you affect them or not
was very Groundhog's Day like these guys
are gonna go through their day and do
their stuff but I can actually have an
effect on that and do something about it
and that changes aspects of the game the
way that they interact and things that
happen in the story so the open world
genres been around now for a while like
last generation we saw sort of like the
big Renaissance were like a lot of other
genres started to bleed into it and
we're now started to see like some
really superb games this year taking
advantage of it
well what do you guys think are like the
sort of the main rules of like this is
what you need to make a really truly
great modern open-world game like going
thread the rest of this year into 2016
Justin what do you think like are
aspects of open-world games that we
require now for a truly wonderful game
that you know you wouldn't have had four
or five years ago in a in a crackdown I
wouldn't have had four or five because I
was just gonna say fishing fishing I
just want to be able to say is it
tattoos is it sweet watches is a
customization I love customization like
things that so I'm always torn on this
like I love GTA and like having all the
different stores and places you can
explore them like giving you a reason to
go to these places but at the same time
like I like having access to all of the
customization as i unlock it which you
know that's always kind of a weird
balance just right guy a good open-world
game makes you feel like you're
accomplishing something whether you are
following the main story or not even if
you're just wandering around you're
going through the world you know you
want to feel like I what I just did was
worthwhile and meaningful and I got
something cool out of it whether I was
helping a dude out in the middle of a
marsh or whether I was following the set
path and going down like here's where I
need to go in the game one of the things
that always I think I'm the type of
person who like I spend my weekends kind
of you know exploring and I like going
cycling on my own I genuinely have
always loved like exploring new places
and for me like in these games I think
the thing that really matters the most
is that it feels like a world in which
something Crazy's just around the corner
that it's it's not like you know I am I
really enjoy which was infamous second
son that came out it was the last year
there before like you look at that I
look at your game like watchdogs like
they they just feel like video game
worlds and you know exactly what's on
bran the next block it's gonna be the
same thing if people on their phones
whatever we're is like a game like which
or you know fall out of Skyrim you kind
of you know
really have that sense of you you know
you can see everything it's kind of like
you've got the blinders on I think that
sense of like wonder and discovery is
maybe the most important thing
my favorite open-world game is walking
through the Tenderloin in San Francisco
exactly San Francisco humor life
imitating art what about yourself either
you played you've played two open-world
games in the past week grande zev
started the phantom pain of course and
i'm mad max what what do you think are
sort of elements that that are important
in like a open-world game in 2015 a
degree of authenticity is needed you
know but it's not required but I think
the two things that are required you
guys both already brought up right which
is feeling like you are a part of a
thing without being the only thing that
is in control and the sense of discovery
in surprise you know like if I think if
the phantom pain was it was a more
consistently like repetitive environment
and like you kind of get the sense of
the begetter you think at the beginning
like home anand all afghanistan is gonna
look the same
yeah I kind of yeah I'm like - I'm six
hours in I guess I mean I'm kind of
thinking oh is this what it is then for
Harold yeah no but no but you find new
things and and and the same thing
happens again when you go to the next
country and it's it is being in a place
that is worth exploring with activities
that are worth doing and you know a
society that's worth participating in
whether that's for better for good or
for evil mmm
you know having a pet helps to I'm
having a pet that can't die that's why
for life or is probably gonna be game
with you 2015 also that's true and yeah
you got you actually horse it seems to
be the but you about the about D horse
got his name yeah D horse Dior is these
time for dog or daughter diamond to
Orange I don't don't yet dog horse right
you got dog me to rid of the house in
Fallout 4 perhaps we'll see got broach
horses you know it is an attention to
detail that's what more open world games
because it's the little things that add
up hmm that's what the D stands for a
detail you tell your daughter's details
on the D and I thank you so much Peter
Brad Justin hey wolf coming in and
talking a whole load of mess about
open-world video games
if you've any thoughts on what makes a
great open-world game please by all
means let us know in the comment box
below